we have very big political news to talk
about today Ohio has decided to switch
to an all by mail Democratic primary
which will run essentially from now
until April 28th and the idea is a good
one Republican Governor Mike DeWine in
Ohio has been one of the best governor's
on the coronavirus response but there
are major concerns about the specifics
of how Ohio is doing this and you'll
very clearly understand why when I give
you the details for context earlier this
week Nancy Pelosi said on MSNBC that in
general because of the virus we should
be switching to mailing in our ballots
and I completely agree Trump doesn't
want this we know why Trump doesn't want
it Trump knows that if more people can
vote more easily in November it's bad
for him it's more likely that he does
not get a second presidential term and
it's good for Democrats so there's this
battle where Nancy Pelosi wants
vote-by-mail Donald Trump does not want
vote-by-mail now you might remember that
the Ohio Democratic primary was
scheduled for Tuesday March 17th that
was sort of like Super Tuesday 3 we had
Super Tuesday on March 3rd colloquially
Super Tuesday - on March 10th and then
Super Tuesday 3 on March 17th Ohio
postponed because of the virus the idea
was to reschedule - June 2nd the new
plan is it will be a mail-in primary in
Ohio and voters will have until April
28th to submit their ballots now in
general this does sound good and indeed
Republican Governor Mike DeWine said he
would sign this bill soon and we can get
started on this vote-by-mail Democratic
primary but there are some concerns that
voters are going to end up
disenfranchised because the way that
this is likely to work out is the Ohio
Secretary of State is going to send out
a postcard
to every registered voter and the
postcard will say hey we're voting by
mail you have to request an absentee
ballot and that is really the source of
the problem here because even if you are
a registered voter you won't get a
ballot automatically you'll get a card
that tells you how to ask for a ballot
now the reason for this and this is true
that the Secretary of State says this
and this is true
the absentee ballot rules as many of you
know in many states are you have to
request an absentee ballot you can't
just send ballots to everybody you have
to have a process whereby someone says I
want an absentee ballot and here's why
that's true but these are special
circumstances these are unprecedented
circumstances so what should be done is
in the coronavirus bill that's being
passed which includes that there's going
to be a vote by mail primary they should
include a provision that changes the
rule it suspends the rule and says we're
gonna send everybody a ballot instead of
a postcard in other words decide as a
legislature this particular circumstance
is so unusual and so different
we need to suspend the you must request
a ballot rule because otherwise the
timeline probably won't work it's April
2nd today that leaves us 26 days for
voting in those 26 days the state needs
to design agree upon a design print and
mail postcards to every registered voter
voters then need to in the midst of
everything everybody's dealing with send
that back or rather go through the
process of asking for a ballot which
according to the Secretary of State's
website you have to print and sign the
ballot request form mail it back by
snail mail those ballots then need to be
sent out be filled out and again you
have to mail that back it's really not
reasonable and the ACLU and other groups
agree this will disenfranchise people so
we need to see how they deal with this
I believe the simplest path is simply
suspend the rule that says you have to
request an absentee ballot say this is
such an extenuating circumstance we're
sending a ballot to everybody now in
terms of the race itself in Ohio the
latest polling we have out of Ohio is
from mid-march things could have changed
since then two polls from mid-march
in one of them Joe Biden is ahead of
Bernie by 23 in another mid-march poll
Joe Biden is ahead of Bernie by 22 it's
been two weeks of virus craziness it's
conceivable that those numbers may have
changed to some degree we don't know but
that is the latest out of Ohio and we
will let you know probably by Monday
there if there's no
advancement on this by Monday we know it
simply is not going to work make sure
that you sign up for the David Pakman
show newsletter at david pakman.com why
next Thursday April ninth we are doing a
one-day membership bomb I told you
yesterday that in March because of the
virus a lot of people are tightening the
belts and we had 389 people cancel
memberships in March that's a record for
us we want to set records for new
members instead we set a record for
canceled memberships we are also on
YouTube experiencing about a 35% revenue
decline again because of what's going on
with the virus so the idea is Thursday
April 9th everybody on our mailing list
will get an email with a special
one-time coupon code we want to have
like a big single day membership drive
to be notified about that discount just
sign up for my mailing list at david
pakman.com in the meantime let me know
on twitter how is the isolation going in
your city town state village country
wherever you are i'm on twitter at d
Pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back after this if you ever feel like
you just don't have enough time to read
all the books you want to read you have
to check out one of my favorite apps
called blinka splink a-- stakes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or audio book that you can get
through in just 15 minutes where you're
getting all the key takeaways from the
book just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge by
being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinka stinkiest has books on
politics philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video